dancy nur is a former advisor to House
Speaker Paul Ryan he spoken with Trump
administration officials and GOP members
of Congress about what we can expect
from tonight's State of the Union good
morning good morning Nora so the White
House is saying this is an opportunity
to unify the country but how can that be
when his day-to-day rhetoric is so
divisive well they argue the White House
argues and members of Congress I spoke
to say look he's got a pretty good
record if you strip away the tweets if
you strip away the noise if you strip
away the volatile behavior tax reform
stock market at record highs devastated
estimating Isis what they believe is
progress in dealing with Iran the move
of the declaring Jerusalem the capital
of Israel there's a series of very
presidential successes here that they
are going to tout and they and they
believe look this could be the beginning
of the re-election campaign for the
House Republican majority which state of
the unions often are and that's you know
that's the message they want to convey
today but Dan the tension in this White
House has been despite those
achievements the president often
undermines his own success with the
public that's why his approval ratings
are low so in a State of the Union do
you think or are they worried and on
Congress on Capitol Hill are they
worried that he threw a tweet beforehand
or afterwards or some other thing
changes the story immediately before the
State of the Union even that's a chance
to settle I mean the news just yet so
here we are the day before the State of
the Union where the running around
touting all these successes they're
gonna highlight in the speech and then
you just a name that's not a household
name take Rodney friedlin hisin all
right he's not a household name all
right he's a Republican member of
Congress in New Jersey 12 term incumbent
he is the chairman of the House
Appropriations Committee members of
Congress spend their lives trying to
become chairman of the House
Appropriations Committee in his first
term as chairman the House
Appropriations Committee he just
announced he's not running for
reelection he's the eighth Republican
Committee Chairman to announce he's not
running for re-election that tells you
where the members heads are at which
they think they are running into real
headwinds so the president has these
successes to tout and he could deliver a
good speech tonight as he did a year ago
as he did in Davos last week but to your
point if there's so much noise and
there's so much friction and there's so
much sort of corrosiveness in the in the
public the public debate and the dialog
it doesn't matter
timing is everything let's talk about
the possible release of the
controversial intelligence memo the
Democrats are calling it reckless you've
talked to some of the Republicans why do
they think it's important that this memo
be released well basically they the
Republicans I've spoken to who are not
of the Devon Nunez group but so the
pointy end of the spear of this is you
know this is revealing some sort of
cover-up that's not the most of them who
are neutral but broadly sympathetic to
the president argue look in in commis
FBI there was unprofessionalism there
was inappropriate behavior in actions in
fact if the basis for this FISA warrant
request was Democratic funded opposition
research that should be exposed that
should be discussed maybe they're you
know different people's positions should
be changed within the organization but
on the other doesn't negate right that
doesn't negate whatever Bob Muller is
working on right now in other words if
Mahler identifies real wrongdoing in
areas of collusion in areas of money
laundering in areas of obstruction of
justice it won't matter what
inappropriate things were done at the
FBI 18 months ago and so there these
these issues are in sort of parallel
tracks but they're not directly
connected and just could be true both
things could be true and just a
clarified that memo is called the Nunez
memo because it is written by
Republicans
it is a cherry-picked the Democrats say
what's that say that's it that's exactly
right that's that's what the Democrats
argue thank you Dan
good you guys Dan will be part of our
CBS News coverage of the president's
State of the Union address beginning
tonight at 9:00 Eastern 8:00 central
right here on CBS John Gail and I will
lead the coverage from New York with
Jeff Glor anchoring from Washington our
entire political team will provide
reporting and analysis